so yesterday I told you about three lies
that Donald Trump appears to have told
recently obviously he spilled way more
than three lies but these are three
recent lies number one I consulted with
generals before issuing the military ban
on transgender servicemembers that
appears to not have been true number two
a Boy Scout official called me and told
me how great my speech was that appears
not to have been true and the Mexican
president called me and said I'm doing a
great job on immigration that also
appears not to have been true all three
are untrue according to the other
parties involved the Pentagon said we
don't know of the generals the Boy
Scouts said no one called Trump Mexico
said our president didn't call Trump now
the White House is admitted to two of
these being lies and of course you have
to sort of read between the lines to
understand the lies because White House
press secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders
confirmed the Boy Scouts liked the
speech and says multiple members of the
Boy Scout leadership went up to trump in
person after the speech and offered
their compliments that's very different
she's arguing the sentiment Trump
expressed is accurate but it just didn't
happen on the phone right it's just an
issue of venue but she was asked well
isn't what the president said a lie then
and she said I wouldn't say it was a lie
that's a pretty bold accusation the
conversations took place they simply
didn't take place over a phone call he
had them in person it's not a bold
accusation I think she's just trying to
get defensive here and you know explain
it away in any way that she can because
what other things could you go to either
that he misspoke or that he was so
having some mental episode or that the
other parties involved they're lying
none of those are good and exactly the
same issue with the Mexican president
phone call again Trump said the Mexican
president called me Sanders said Oh know
what Trump meant was last month at the
g20 in Germany he spoke to the Mexican
president and that's when the topic of
immigration came up understand the
argument here right both times
Trump alleges that phone calls took
place both times
Sarah Huckabee Sanders says well the
gist of what Trump said was accurate but
the phone call didn't actually happen in
order to believe Trump wasn't lying you
have to basically believe he can't
distinguish or recall the difference
between a phone call and an
person conversation if you're trying to
argue that the president is competent
lucid and generally with it it's not a
good idea to say he doesn't know the
difference between talking to someone on
the phone and talking to someone in
person and again these are these lies
are demonstrably and provably false
that's the fascinating thing Trump
thinks he's smart enough to get one over
on people he thinks he's such a good
liar that he's going to be able to say
whatever he wants and people will be
impressed rather than figure out that
he's telling lies and he's not that good
of a liar and all the signs of a
pathological liar too because these are
such trivial topics I mean what does it
matter if your speech to the Boy Scouts
was the best ever
where if pena nieto thinks that you're
doing a great job on Mexican immigration
or if you consulted with UN it's just
like it's not as if he's trying to pass
some policy and trying to deceive the
American people in that way they're not
a lie and they're not lies that helped
him achieve a particular end that's why
it seems so weird and I mean remember
when he got a letter from the NFL and
there was no such letter remember when
he lied about the weather on
inauguration day and it was actually
worse he actually claimed that God held
the rain back until the inauguration was
over which is ridiculous but there's
also video of it raining during the
inauguration it's just very very bizarre
and any time you have to defend a world
leader as a press secretary by saying
they're not a liar they're just either
dumb or can't remember anything then
you're already on the defensive and
maybe Trump what what other explanation
is there like maybe Trump thinks when he
talks to someone on the phone there's a
person in the phone rather than like
that's somebody somewhere else calling
him I'm just trying to think outside the
box here so what explanations there
could be where this wouldn't be a lie by
Trump there are a few explanations but
none are good and I think that's why the
communications directors keep going out
the door and why he can't hold on to a
press secretary now but Sarah Huckabee
Sanders got to give her credit she's
holding her own there if Trump can't
tell the difference between talking to
someone on the phone and talking to
someone in person isn't it likely he
might not be able to tell the difference
between the send nuke button and the
send tweet button like is that a
reasonable concern if he genuinely can't
tell the difference I mean sometimes I
hit reply all when I just mean to hit
reply that'll have
to me I've said it before and I'll say
it again this will be the retroactive
defense of the Russia scandal we listen
it's very clear that this is an
organized White House we never could
have possibly colluded with Russia and
that's kind of what Jared Krishnan is
already saying he said something
recently about we couldn't have colluded
with Russia because our campaign office
was just really really unorganized plead
ignorance when nothing else works